bonjour merci d'être avec nous lors
l'actualité c'est ce conseil de défense
demain que va provoquer emmanuel macron
que doit-on en attendre je pense qu'on
doit on attendre une relation entre les
deux pays qui vont prendre en main au
plus haut niveau cette crise qui s'est
produite au niger avec l'attak dont ont
été victimes les humanitaires leur ville
et leur chauffeur
cela signifie que ces prix très au
sérieux à la fois par le chef de l'état
nigérien qui après a présenté ses
condoléances aux familles endeuillées et
par le président français également qui
est un des partenaires des pays du g5
sahel dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
dans cette région alors les auteurs
n'ont pas été identifiés un pour
l'instant il pourrait s'agir de membres
d'un groupe un groupe encore peu connue
affiliés à l'organisation état islamique
dans le grand sahara qui est ce groupe
pour l'instant il est difficile de dire
avec précision ce qui s'est passé est ce
qu'il s'agit d'une attaque crapuleuses
elle qu'il s'agit de l'action de
coupeurs de routes ou de terroristes
pour l'instant aqmi a dit que ça ne
concernait pas les autorités nigérianes
ont engagé les investigations pour
pourra dire avec certitude d'où venait
la tête et qu'il a perpétrés nous sommes
malheureusement obligés d'attendre
d'avoir les conclusions de tout cela
pour savoir
très concrètement qu'est derrière
l'attaqué mais une chose est certaine
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le pays et atteint
à plusieurs niveaux tout d'abord il ya
ces victimes qui sont étrangères et qui
pose un problème par rapport à
l'hospitalité des nigériens ils se
sentent un peu coupable de n'avoir pas
pu assurer la sécurité de leur zone et
n'avoir dont pas répondu aux besoins de
l'hospitalité dont il avait besoin et
par ailleurs c'est également un
repoussoir pour les investisseurs qui
estiment maintenant encore plus qu'avant
que ce pays n'est pas sûre en terme de
sécurité pourrait investir de l'argent
dont je pense qu'on est dans un contexte
où il ya beaucoup de douleur il ya
beaucoup de peine de la part des
autorités et donc forcément il y aura
une enquête diligentée
le plus sérieusement possible pour
assurer à la fois les familles qui ont
perdu les leurs également pour rassurer
les investisseurs parce que c'est une
zone qui est touristique c'est un pays
qui a besoin d'investissements et donc
pour toutes ces raisons là je pense
qu'ils prendront très au sérieux à la
fois au niger et en france les enquêtes
qui vont être menées pour déterminer à
la fois les circonstances et les auteurs
de l'attaqué
est ce que le sel est en train de
devenir un repaire de dia disque
personne n'arrive à contenir là on est
dans une région du sahel c'est à dire la
zone des trois frontières entre le niger
le mali et le burkina faso qui est très
poreuse et quand on dit trois frontières
on est on ne mesure pas que là ya
également le bénin et que le nigeria
n'est pas si loin que ça donc plutôt que
trois frontières on a presque 5
frontières et des pays qui ne
travaillent pas suffisamment les uns
avec les autres pour effacer la menace
djihadiste à laquelle ils font face
ensemble et donc là il ya un besoin pour
les pays de véritablement prendre à
coeur la lutte contre le terrorisme
il ya un besoin pour les populations de
s'y associer également parce que à elles
seules les autorités qui ont pendant
longtemps été en marge de deux qui n'ont
pas été présents toujours aux zones de
frontière ne peuvent pas réinvestir cela
et ciel réinvestissent uniquement sur le
plan militaire
ce que les militaires gagneront ils il y
avait les populations n'arriveront pas
le gagner une fois une autre une attaque
lancée
donc le volet militaire est important
mais il faudrait également un volet
économie un volet social et en volley de
développement qui manque cruellement
pour sécuriser les victoires militaires
dans cette région du sahel qui est
devenu comme vous le rappelez un repère
pour les terroristes
dans cette partie du continent africain
concrètement éminemment de coordination
un manque de partage d'informations
entre les pays du g5 sahel
au début il ya eu un manque de
coordination et de partage
d'informations mais je pense que depuis
les choses ont évolué on a de plus en
plus de pays africains qui travaillent
ensemble d'abord dans le cadre du g5
sahel ensuite dans le cadre plus large
de la communauté économique et de
développement des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest qui est coordonné actuellement
par le niger justement et puis à tous
les partenaires internationaux
il ya la france et à l'union européenne
et puis il ya le système des nations
unies qui sont en train de s'investir
parce que cette zone est devenue le
ventre mou de la sécurité en afrique de
l'ouest et il faut très rapidement
remédier à cela parce que si jamais le
terrorisme et tous les trafics qui se
déroule prenait racine et n'était pas
combattu je pense que c'est toute la
bande sahélo saharienne
mais au delà de la bande parce que le
niger est traversé par au moins deux
courants terroriste ya celui du nord
avec aqmi al qaïda et tous les autres et
puis à au sud
tout ce qui est lié à boko haram donc
tout cela pourrait se mélanger y avoir
une extension qui dépasserait les
frontières du niger et de l'afrique de
l'ouest pour toucher l'afrique centrale
et l'afrique de l'est
donc il est urgent aujourd'hui pour les
pays de travailler ensemble dans la zone
du sahel mais de façon plus large au
niveau de la cedeao au niveau des pays
du maghreb et même que l'union africaine
qui est l'instance continentale prennent
à coeur le sujet à côté des
nations-unies à côté de tous les
partenaires internationaux pour que
personne ne manque à l'appel à l'effort
général qui est nécessaire pour
combattre les terroristes
oui keumayou merci d'avoir répondu à une
question de rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et président du club de
l'information africaine merci